without naming names have you ever
worked with a bad director a bad
director no no I know I really haven't I
mean there have been directors that
whose vision of the project and taken on
my particular character didn't
necessarily jive with what I showed up
with to work with again it's I think you
have to be willing to just be part of
the process you know if I'm a seventeen
million dollar a list guy then I feel
like maybe I have more of an opportunity
to say you know what no no this is the
way I think this role should be played
and and your take on it is hogwash
forget it well I you know I can't say
that so you know I'll I'll go with what
the director wants me to do and and
sometimes you feel like oh this is gonna
be hot this is gonna be the worst thing
in the world and it's gonna ruin
everything that I wanted to bring to
this role and it's not going to be what
I thought it would be
you have to do it you have to suck it up
and you know be willing to take
direction and and that's just the way it
is it did happen once on a show and this
was more of a technical direction that
turned out badly than anything else the
star I was in a room full of people and
I had to deliver a line to the star of
the show down at the far end of a table
we were sitting in a long table and he
was down at the end and I just you know
I said the line and I saw him the star
motion to the director and the director
came over and he whispered something in
the director's ear and the director said
Steve can you say the line a little
louder please
well yeah sure don't do that so we did
it again and the same thing kind of
happened and I and I generally got the
idea that the guy at the end of the
table the star couldn't hear me he was
having trouble hearing me and so we did
the take two or three times and every
time I was asked to speak a little
louder so he could pick up his cue from
me because he couldn't hear me and the
take that they finally used in on the
show when I watched it was me screaming
this line to the doctor at the end of
the table and it's it was ridiculous it
made me sound ridiculous it kind of
ruined the scene in my opinion but he
heard me and he got his cue and the
scene continued and that was that and
was I happy with it no but I wasn't you
know in a position where I could really
fight for it or do anything else I mean
what the guy couldn't hear me what are
you gonna do I so you just do it is that
what about an inexperienced director
maybe the great person you know very
friendly tone onset but you can tell
maybe they're a little indecisive or
something again same same rule applies I
mean you said you you didn't feel like
you had the license to say something
well at me at that point in my career
this was just a co-star on on a on a
wildly popular show and I and I was just
kind of a day player and I didn't feel
like I could say anything I think um if
it's an inexperienced director I might
at this point in my career be willing to
go off to the side with him and and you
know say you know what I'm I'm thinking
that it might be interesting to try it
this way and and here's why I think that
and that it added on and I you know I'm
not sure what you're trying to
accomplish with your direction and I'm
certainly willing to try that but I I'd
like you to maybe entertain the option
of of trying it another way when we're
fit when we're finished doing what you
would like us to do sure yeah I don't
see anything wrong with that
you